bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de la différence qui existe entre la
fusion et la fission nucléaire
dans cette vidéo je vais pas du tout
abordé la question leur différence
d'impact technologiques
environnementales ou économique je
voudrais juste me concentrer sur la
différence de phénomènes physiques qui a
entre les deux parce qu'il ya quand même
un truc paradoxal dans cette histoire je
peux produire de l'énergie en prenant
deux atomes et en les fusionnant mais si
je peux produire aussi l'énergie en
prenant un atom et en le fusionnant
pourquoi est ce que je fais pas l'un
puis l'autre alternativement je fusionne
officiel je fusionne le fit sienne etc
et puis comme ça on produirait de
l'énergie au gratuit et illimité et sans
consommer une seule ressource et puis on
pourrait faire du mouvement perpétuel
aussi tant qu'on y est non bien
évidemment tout ça ça ne marche pas et
on va essayer de comprendre pourquoi
la première chose qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que quand on parle de produire de
l'énergie
en fait c'est un terme incorrect on
produit pas de l'énergie ont l'extrait
pour comprendre ça on peut prendre
l'exemple d'une centrale hydroélectrique
qui serait situé au niveau d'un barrage
l'eau s'écoule du haut vers le bas et on
en profite pour faire tourner une
turbine et produire de l'électricité et
en faisant ça on n'a pas produit de
l'énergie
on a juste récupérer extrait l'énergie
qui était contenu dans l'eau du fait de
sa position élevée c'est ce qui
s'appelle l'énergie potentielle de
pesanteur l'ol est passé d'un état
d'énergie élevée à un état d'énergie
plus faible et nous on a récupéré la
différence ou du moins une partie de la
différence dans une combustion il se
passe exactement la même chose si vous
prenez du gaz par exemple du méthane et
que vous faites brûler vous avez une
réaction chimique qui transforme les
molécules de gaz en eau et en gaz
carbonique et l'énergie chimique dans la
molécule de méthane
elle est plus élevée que celle qui est
contenu dans l'eau elle co2 donc on a pu
extraire la différence sous forme de
chaleur en bref produire de l'énergie
c'est prendre un truc qui est dans un
état d'énergie élevée et le mettre dans
un état d'énergie plus faible en
récupérant la différence alors
maintenant qu'on a compris ça on peut
regarder le cas de la fission nucléaire
pour faire de la fiction il vous faut un
gros atome que vous allez casser en deux
alors petit rappel avant de rentrer dans
le vif du sujet un atom ce sont des
électrons qui tourne autour d'un noyau
alors les électrons aujourd'hui on va un
peu les oubliés le noyau lui il est fait
deux protons et de neutrons le nombre de
protons détermine la nature de l'atome
c'est à dire son nom et sa position dans
le tableau de mendeleïev par exemple un
noyau avec 12 proton c'est du magnésium
les neutrons en général y en a à peu
près autant que de protons voir un
chouïa plus et si on fait la somme
proton plus neutre où on à la masse
atomique du noyau qui est le numéro
qu'on place après le nom de l'atome
par exemple 12 proton et 12 neutrons
c'est du magnésium 24 et en général il
existe plusieurs variantes pour chaque
atome par exemple on trouve aussi du
magnésium 25-12 proton 13 neutrons et du
magnésium 26-12 proton 14 neutrons bon
voilà pour la manière dont on nomme les
noyaux mais maintenant revenons à la
fission on a dit qu'il nous fallait un
gros atome
par exemple un atomes d'uranium 235 on
peut le cas c'est pour obtenir un atome
de baryum et un atome de krypton et la
raison qui fait que ça produit de
l'énergie
c'est que l'énergie contenue dans le
noyau d'uranium
les plus élevées que celles contenues
dans les noyaux de baryum et de krypton
pris ensemble et à cause de cette
différence d'énergie la réaction de
fission elle produit de la chaleur qu'on
peut récupérer par exemple pour faire de
l'électricité
là je vous ai donné l'exemple de la
fission de l'uranium en barres y sommes
et krypton mais des réactions de fission
pour l'uranium 235 en fait y en a plein
d'autres et elles se produisent tout à
des degrés divers mais un point
important qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
que ces réactions de fission elles se
produisent pas tout seul il faut
provoquer la fission en faisant absorber
à l'atome d'uranium
un neutron et le truc qui fait que ça
marche c'est que la fission elle va
aussi émettre des neutrons elle va en
mettre trois qui vont pouvoir à leur
tour à l'étape et d'autres noyaux et
provoquer d'autres fission et ainsi de
suite
et c'est ça qui provoque le phénomène de
réaction en chaîne si c'est neutre où il
n'était pas émis les réactions ne
pourrait pas s'auto entretenir on voit
donc que pour avoir une réaction en
chaîne et donc pour avoir la possibilité
d'extraire de l'énergie par fission
nucléaire
la réaction doit avoir des
caractéristiques très particulières à
cette capacité à absorber et émettre des
neutrons et ya que très peu de noyaux
qui ont les bonnes caractéristiques il
ya essentiellement que l'uranium 235 et
le plutonium 239 l'uranium 235 on le
trouve à l'état naturel mais seulement
en très petite quantité à la majorité de
l'uranium naturel est en fait de
l'uranium 238 cas pas les bonnes
propriétés et c'est pour ça qu'on est
obligé d'avoir un processus pour
centrifugé l'uranium et enrichir en
uranium 235 et les centrifugeuses qu'on
utilise ce sont elles qui sont au coeur
de tous ces débats et toutes ces
polémiques qui assure le contrôle de la
prolifération nucléaire
le plutonium 239 lui il n'existe pas du
tout à l'état naturel mais on peut le
produire à partir de l'uranium 238 en
lui balançant des neutrons donc voilà
l'uranium 235 plutonium 239 ce sont les
deux éléments d'ailleurs qu'on retrouve
dans les bombes atomiques
il existe un troisième élément moins
connus qu'on peut utiliser pour faire de
la fission nucléaire c'est l'uranium 233
l'uranium 233 il n'existe pas non plus à
l'état naturel mais on peut le fabriquer
artificiellement en balançant des
neutrons sont du thorium 232 et ça c'est
le principe de la filière nucléaire dit
au thorium c'est une filière qui est pas
du tout utilisé aujourd'hui mais il ya
un certain nombre de personnes qui
poussent pour la développer bon voilà ça
c'était pour la fission maintenant on va
passer à la fusion
le principe de la fusion à première vue
celle inverse de la fission on prend
deux atomes par exemple d'hydrogène et
on les fusionne pour en obtenir qu'un
seul par exemple de l'hélium
cette réaction pour qu'elle marche il
faut passer par des variantes de
l'hydrogène qu'on appelle le deutérium
qui a un neutron en plus de son proton
et le tritium qui a deux neutrons dans
les réacteurs à fusion la réaction qu'on
essaye de faire c'est donc celle ci est
cette réaction de fusion elles libèrent
de l'énergie puisque contrairement à ce
qu'on avait avec l'uranium l'énergie des
deux atomes d'hydrogène
elle est plus élevée que l'énergie de
l'atome d'hélium et donc on peut
récupérer la différence alors la fusion
nucléaire c'est aussi ce qui permet aux
étoiles de briller même si la chaîne est
un petit peu plus compliqué que ce qu'on
appellera comme dans le cas de la
fission de l'uranium cette réaction de
fusion elle se produit pas de manière
spontanée
encore heureux sinon ça voudrait dire
que quand on approche deux atomes
d'hydrogène l'un de l'autre ils
pourraient fusionner libéré de l'énergie
non pour que la réaction de fusion se
produise il faut d'abord l'allumé en
injectant de l'énergie alors ça peut
paraître un peu bizarre de dire qu'il
faut injecter l'énergie pour ensuite
pouvoir en produire mais c'est
exactement le principe de la barrière
énergétique on va prendre une analogie
la barrière énergétique c'est exactement
ce qui se passerait avec un barrage
hydroélectrique dont l'eau serait au
départ contenu dans un petit lac
encaissé en altitude il faudrait d'abord
dépenser un peu d'énergie pour faire
sortir l'eau de la cuve est avant de
récupérer plus d'énergie que ce qu'on
avait mis au départ grâce à descendre
dans la vallée ce principe c'est aussi
celui de l'allumette si vous prenez du
bois ou bien du gaz naturel et que vous
les mettez en contact avec de l'oxygène
ils se mettent pas à brûler spontanément
et pourtant l'énergie de la molécule de
gaz naturel
elle est plus élevée que l'énergie
contenue dans les produits de la
réaction la raison c'est qu'il ya une
barrière énergétique et l'allumette elle
sert à ça elle sert à apporter un peu
d'énergie pour passer la barrière
énergétique et ensuite on récupère plus
d'énergie que ce qu'on avait mis au
départ avec l'allumette et la réaction
s'auto entretient le problème c'est que
dans le cas de la fusion nucléaire il
faut vraiment une grosse allumette pour
initier la réaction quand on fait une
bombe h conquis une bombe à fusion
nucléaire
on utilise comme allumettes une bombe a
c'est à dire une bombe atomique à
fission juste comme allumettes et dans
les étoiles ce qui tient lieu
d'allumettes c'est le fait que le nuage
d'hydrogène s'effondre sur lui-même ses
chauffe beaucoup et c'est ça qui
permettent d'enclencher la réaction est
donc tout le jeu de ceux qui s'efforcent
de maîtriser la fusion nucléaire pour
produire de l'énergie avec c'est de
créer les bonnes conditions pour pouvoir
initier emma
la réaction enfin d'une manière
différente que de faire sauter une bombe
à ça c'est de la fusion incontrôlée
alors passons maintenant aux trucs
paradoxale de la sphère dont j'ai parlé
au début de la vidéo comment ça se fait
que quand on prend de l'uranium il ya
plus d'énergie dans un atome que dans 2
mai avec l'hydrogène et l'hélium il ya
plus d'énergie dans deux atomes que dans
en fait la raison c'est que les atomes
qui ont le moins d'énergie les atomes
les plus stables
ce sont les atomes de taille moyenne la
courbe que vous voyez ici elle vous
montre l'énergie moyenne d'un noyau en
fonction de sa taille elle est très
élevé pour les petits atomes
elle passe par un minimum autour du fer
et du nickel et elle remonte pour les
gros atome main cette courbe d'énergie
c'est exactement comme une vallée dans
laquelle se baladerait un cours d'eau on
peut récupérer un peu d'énergie en
passant de là à la sas et la fission et
on peut récupérer beaucoup d'énergie en
passant de là à là et ça c'est la fusion
et le faire lui évincé l'atome le plus
stable
il ne peut ni fusionner ni fissionner
cette histoire de barrières énergétique
elle permet aussi de comprendre un autre
phénomène qui allait relier mais qui est
différent c'est la radioactivité la
radioactivité on peut la comparer à la
fission mais c'est une forme de fission
ou le noyau ne perdrait qu'un tout petit
morceau
vous savez que la plupart des atomes
peuvent exister sous diverses formes
plus ou moins abondante par exemple le
carbone bonga si proton et bien il
existe le carbone 12 qui en plus assis
neutrons le carbone 13 qui en a 7 et le
carbone 14 qui en a huit
oui quand on donne le numéro après le
nom d'un élément ça désigne la somme
proton plus neutre on est bien le
carbone 14
il peut se transformer en azote 14 en
émettant notamment un électron et si
cette réaction elle est possible c'est
parce que l'énergie contenue dans le
carbone 14
elle est encore une fois supérieure à
l'énergie contenue dans les produits de
la réaction mais comme dans le cas de la
fusion la transformation elle est pas
spontané il ya une petite barrière
énergétique a passé pour qu'elles se
produisent
il faudrait que quelque chose joue le
rôle d'une allumette en pratique dans la
nature ya pas vraiment d'allumettes qui
permettent de sauter cette barrière
énergétique il ya quelque chose à
prendre en compte c'est l'effet tunnel
j'en avais parlé dans ma vidéo sur la
mécanique quantique l'effet tunnel
il est tel que de temps en temps
certaines particules peuvent sauter des
barrières énergétique
un peu comme si un petit tunnel se
creuser et c'est ça qui provoque la
désintégration du carbone 14 et d autres
éléments radioactifs mais c'est d'une
manière aléatoire
et plus la barrière est haute plus
l'effet tunnel est improbable et c'est
ça qui explique que les éléments
radioactifs ont tous des durées de vie
différentes elles sont plus longues
quand la barrière est haute et plus
courte quand la barrière est faible dans
le cas du carbone 14 ce qu'on appelle la
2010 elle est de 5400 ans et c'est cette
caractéristique qui rend le carbone 14
idéal pour faire de la datation d'objets
anciens mais bon il ya quelques
subtilités et il faudra exemple parle
plus précisément dans une prochaine
vidéo
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la partager
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que comme toujours c'est le meilleur
moyen que vous ayez pour m'aider à faire
connaître la chaîne vous pouvez suivre
l'actualité de la chaîne notamment sur
facebook et sur twitter
vous pouvez si vous le souhaitez nous
soutenir sur technique sommes toujours
merci beaucoup à tous les types qui me
soutiennent et puis vous pouvez aussi
vous retrouver sur mon blog s'appelle
science étonnante merci à bientôt